Christina el Moussa shuts down the  haters and then stuns in a gorgeous gown  a mom that can do both the max that  would be flip or flop star Christina el  Moussa the 33 year old HGTV star  defended herself on social media after  followers criticized her for this photo  she posted to Instagram Friday mommy  shavers came out in full force giving  her a hard time over how close her  one-year-old son Brayden was to the pool  to which she responded quote thanks for  your concern aka judgment I am right  there and could be to him in three  seconds shaking my head at this after  putting the haters in their place the  mother of two stunned in a photo shoot  Christina posted this pic to the gram on  Saturday rocking a form-fitting black  gown with gold lace accents and a  plunging neckline she paired the look  with a simple gold bracelet and gold  stud earrings compresses me every day  you